pablo lopez has been really really good
especially his last two starts and one
thing that i was looking at his two
games with sandy leone behind the dish
a .69 er8 carson kelly their catcher
sitting 333 he's got a half a dozen
homers 17 batted in
all right 0 and 2 2 on 2 outs here's the
pitch swing and a miss strike 3
got him with the four seam fastball and
strikeout number one on the night for
pablo and that takes care of the
diamondbacks here in the first inning
they strand a couple had one hit the
lead off hit
by pavon smith now the marlins come to
bat next
yeah well madison garner's coming off a
couple good starts one of them where the
the start before his last he went
seven innings no hit baseball miguel
rojas batting 271
bumgarner over the years been a really
good pitcher here's the 2-1
and this ball is smacked and it is high
and it is headed toward that scoreboard
above the bullpen and left it is up
up and away there is a home run for
miguel
his first of 2021. you were just talking
about how
miguel has really picked it up now he's
collected the long ball for the first
time this year
an opportunity here for pavement smith
to perhaps tie this ball game up with a
base hit
silvar shows at second bumgarner at
first two down for paybit who singled
his first time
even smith drives one to the gap and
that's going to get to the wall
varshall is home madison bumgarner
chugging into third and we are tied at
one
paving smith the rbi double 1-1 game
second and third now
still too out of the ending and the
batter will be cabrera who was hit by
pitch
his first time up pablo kicks fires away
the 1-1
swing and a pop-up out into shallow
center here comes brinson he's got a
beat on this
gets under it and makes the catch for
the third out
cabrera pops it up to louis brinson good
pitch there by
lopez and he takes care of business here
but uh
the the error and then the hit batter
really got him in trouble and pavon
smith made him pay for that with that
rbi double 1-1 and the marlins coming up
in their half of the second
and now anderson who has hurt the
diamondbacks in his career and in this
series
bumgarner set and the two to pitch
swinging a miss game to chase off the
plate first strikeout for bumgarner and
that's not number one here in the second
here's chad wallach now two outs here in
the second bumgarner trying to put him
away one two three
the wind up and the pitch he struck him
out swinging strikes out the side
and a nice quick one two three inning
for the mad bump that brings pablo lopez
to the plate pablo
who by the way is a right-hand pitcher
but he
bats left-handed he'll step in here
against the lefty
madison bumgarner here's a one-two
and struck him out swinging that's five
straight case
for the big lefty two up two down yeah
keep it going right now he had no chance
no breaking ball he was swinging and
getting out of there
garrett cooper he had a deep fly ball to
left first time up
on ball two strikes the next one to
cooper
swaying and a miss fastball heater and
up in the zone he didn't get it
strikeout number six
for bob garner and two up two down here
in the fourth inning
here's ass drubal cabrera he was hit by
a pitch in the first
popped up in the second
swing and a miss there and that's
one two three four five strikeouts now
for pablo
so first and third and carson kelly the
batter he has struck out and walked
josh rojas in third david peralta at
first two balls two strikes two outs
here it is from lopez
swing and a miss he makes the pitch
pablo struck him
out and i'm not sure what the reaction
was but
the hitter carson kelly seemed perplexed
by the pitch
and he looked back at the catcher and
the marlins are walking off the field
and kelly was slow to leave the batters
box
here's brunson that bump trying to
strike out his 7th
or man least getting out here anyway can
get it out right
don't worry about it get it out into the
wind up he goes to the 0-2 pitch
got him swinging another breaking ball
princeton might have hurt himself on
that swing
two up two down curveball way out of the
zone and
what brenson was swinging out but it
never even came close to the plate
two on and two out for garrett cooper
two on two out cooper swings and hits it
down to third as cabrera's got it and he
throws to sing it
to uh van meter for the first play on
aguilar to win the inning
no runs one hit two left first two
stranded tonight by the fish here's
as drubal cabrera he got hit by a pitch
in the first inning
popped up to center field in the second
and struck out in the fifth and bats
here
in inning number seven cabrera with a
fly ball to deep right center field
and at the top of the wall
magneris sierra brings it back what a
play
at the top of the wall in right center
magnificent from magna race
as an outfitter it is so hard to really
squeeze the baseball and hold on to it
look where he caught it oh he bobbled it
the ball came out
wow jb buscaskis
is in the game he'll face duvall
duvall lifts one high and deep left
center field gives it a ride
goodbye home run adam duvall
marlins taking lead in the seventh a
home run to break up a 1-1
game duvall gives the marlins a 2-1 lead
so chad wallach gets a shot at trying to
get that runner in from third base
becomes a 1-1 to wallet and this ball
is hit high and deep to right center
going back
rojas on the track hauls it in
easy play for anderson to tag up and
come home
on a sac fly by chad wallach
and the marlins have a three to one lead
here in the seventh
eduardo escobar to the plate eighth
inning marlins lead 3-1
here's the pitch and first ball hitting
he skies one out to right center and
sierra is under this
he's got it and that ends the inning so
a little anti-clematic for the
diamondbacks there and that they had
something going got the big man escobar
to the plate
as a pinch hitter and he popped it up
the center field
and as drubal cabrera who started the
game at third base finishing up at first
base he's the batter
payoff pitch coming into right
that's duvall it's a marlins win